CARSON SOU
OPENING PERIOD IT'S PITTSBURGH
PASS NOT GOING TO SEE
CROSBY. POINT STREAK, GREAT
START FOR  IN FRONT, ENDS UP
GOING THROUGH WHETHER SIDNEY  W
THAT, FINDS IT RIGHT THERE, GON.
PICKED
HEINEN N
BUT KRA
KAPANEN.
OFF A STICK, WIDE.
NOW BOUNCED OFF THE CORNER.
NOW MOVEDPRESSURE.
TANEV ON HIM.
PLAYED ALONG THE BOARDS.
BACK FOR
JARED McCANN,
THURSDAY NIGHT, WINNIPEG JETS IN
WELCOME BACK TO THE LINEUP
JORDAN EBERLE! WITH
EBERLE AND WENNBERG AND IT'S IN
THE BACK OF THE NET.CANN, HE HA
FIVE POWER PLAY GOALS, FE PUCK.
WENNBERG MOVED ACROSS
LAUZON AT THE POINT, WEDGED
WIDE.
LOOKINGADY,
ON AND OFF THE STICK, A LITTLE
BIT TOO
STOPPED BY DACCORD.
REBOUND IS CASH IN BY JEFF
CARTER
WHAT A SAVE DACCORD ON THAT
TWO-ON-ONE.
A LITTLE BIT OF LUC
PLAYS IT BACK FOR LARSSON.
WILL SHIFT IN STATUS.
NOW FROM
TANEV TO SET THUP PLAY
DUNN.
DONSKOI, BROKEN UP, O'CONNOR SO.
GOOD STICK BY KASPERI KAPANEN. .
GUENTZEL OFFER THE SKATE.
WASTE NO TIME,